Jay had originally been asked by MTV to do this mashup thing.
And they said, you know, "Who do you wanna do this thing with?"
He said, "Linkin Park".
And I sent him "Numb / Encore" which ended up being a single in one of them.
From there we just kinda realized that we see eye to eye on a lot of stuff.
I asked him to be my executive producer on it.
And he agreed to do that so it kinda became a real album at that point.
I tend to be all over the place, like I can do a lot of different things.
I'm versatile when it comes to the studio.
And I wanted somebody who can look over my shoulder and say,...
...you know, "Keep that song, don't keep that song,"...
...and "Keep working on this one, it's not done yet".
What he did do was tell me when I was really on task,...
...when I was making songs that were right for the album.